francamente es difícil es difícil tener
uno muy muy claro lo que sí me parece
evidente y creo que los franceses lo han
manifestado muchísimas veces es que cada
vez que la decisión que tomar pues ha
sido tomada con mucho retraso y
finalmente el gobierno francés se
después de un año muestra que siempre en
lugar de estar en la acción en la
proactividad está siempre una reacción
tardía y no le hace caso a la ciencia y
finalmente pues termina tomando medidas
cuando es demasiado tarde esperemos que
a pesar de eso se logre mitigar un poco
la crisis que nos trae la nueva variante
pero pues el balance es este que ha
demostrado una una incompetencia del
gobierno a anticiparse las cosas y hacer
de caso la ciencia ahora cree usted que
con una medida de exigir esta prueba
negativa el psr se emite y graba un poco
la propagación del virus
pues al menos se mitigará la entrada del
virus al país y eso ya de por sí es una
cosa positiva es mejor esta solución que
de cerrar las fronteras pues los
estudios también han demostrado que
serra las contras no es suficiente sin
embargo si no hay una pedagogía y si no
hay realmente unas acciones del gobierno
para comprender pues hay que entender
que la aplicación es interna más que
externa